[Music]
all right so this week we got creepy
fashion ooh
snapchat rent my specialty okay and
unexpected birth whoa take it away to
you good hmm juicy detail birth yeah
birth attack you know when you're like
oh [ __ ] I know what that's like I don't
know about you I do too after legendary
birth unexpected first I'll talk about
the guy version of it you know sometimes
you go here like Malaysian food and you
haven't had Malaysia bacteria and get
the fungus and all of a sudden mm-hmm
all right well for a story there's this
creepy fanny pack that gives you big
hairy people they've been sending me
this [ __ ] cuz they know i wear fanny
packs that is awesome that's it's huge
it is huge you can put a [ __ ] big ass
beep yeah red stripe oh yeah it is a red
stripe your favorite come on so Jamaican
beer right I thought you used to come in
that bottle to bought yeah the the the
stubby bottles that is creepy yeah this
artist created it saying I don't know if
he's done pretty sure he's joking but it
sounds like you think serious he's like
I've always wanted a dad bod but I know
who the [ __ ] says that [ __ ] you and your
perfect body no he was like it's just
that you know I am very aware of the
health risks so I created this fanny
pack this six-pack you know like it just
doesn't allow for the dad bod like how
do it like six-packs you know I like how
he has a hairy underbelly yeah it's kind
of cool looks like a beard oh yeah it's
like a chin words do oh yeah I do that
very on the bottom oh yeah now you
[ __ ] me up committee feel about this
so they feel like they're being dad
bashing
I'm against this I feel shamed I feel
made fun of my stomach looks exactly
like that just dagger but if people are
buying it it's kind of cool because now
it's like I'm sorry dislike slice my
[ __ ] and start so there are six
different styles oh what's the white I
don't want those tear on their hair the
semen
oh the Shirelles like the she-man the
wolf's game is like the Sun burnt one
yeah Wolfgang are these on milk because
I'm being sexist right now I'm thinking
they're all male right okay I'm not
being sexist what's the Magnus like a
man's anus yeah well I thought is it the
mangina
we're four in this little thing that's
like a really big guy that lost weight
and then now the loose skin yeah loose
skin loose yeah no lipo do you guys want
to buy one of these fun oh no I have
[ __ ] something like that right now I
even tried I don't like the one I have I
would not pay for a new one that would
be cool you have another one why buy one
if you already go they should do the ass
version in aspersion with oh so now you
wear the fanny pack on the video yeah
you should tell me please tell me pack
that or there's some people wear it this
way yeah maybe just want it you know
like you should get uh royalties you're
expanding his product line you pay me
let's talk my people your people would
it be insensitive there was like a
pregnant addition oh yeah what does that
look like oh just be really good belly
but you got any more though it'd be a
way bigger belly so it's like a full Sun
yeah but for your stomach it's like the
pregnant addition I don't know what that
means
like a banner
I like it I'm not hurt by that are you
hurt might not know mean I do like the
shirts though that that like it they'll
have the girl perfect like girl in the
bikini whatever I like that shirt and
then the guy aversion to or the guys all
shredded that picture that we're the one
with the tuxedo we're look like you're
wearing one too
oh yeah yeah that's cool they have a
bikini from women but it's like a hairy
man body oh it's a one-piece right yeah
yeah and it's supposed to go make you go
I don't know I think they're gag gifts I
don't think it's real
Rick is talking about completely
different it's like on a model it [ __ ]
it's very realistic your body is really
nice and then the [ __ ] dick area I'm
like what happened out oh the dick is
there no I think they photoshopped it
out or like it goes all the way down
like right before the dick
oh so there's no dick on this Oh some
won't you wear that with that nutsack
backpack this is how you know we have
too much time on our hands it's a great
country to live in
yeah other countries are like you guys
are [ __ ] crazy
yeah can you imagine like Chinese people
in factories building this [ __ ] they're
like 12 years old and the legs why you
wanna wear this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I
don't care no or whatever it's the
opposite effect like oh this is a new
shoe no so this thing is called the dad
bag so it's not curly currently
available the artist he's saying that
he's looking for investors to see if we
could like mass-produce it but they
already have like 10 capable he does not
need investors bro just [ __ ] go to
China and you can start I wouldn't be
surprised if someone already copied this
[ __ ] it started putting it on market cuz
you it's on Alibaba
we're yeah like a couple weeks ago when
it came out everybody was posting that
[ __ ] yeah so they now have it makes me
want to puke when I look at it
why Wow insensitive much you see so
highly a [ __ ] server just like you had
one of these that's why nuke every
morning it reminds me of me and how
delicious food is my and it's like I see
it and I'm like ah damn sodas so [ __ ]
good
yeah well they have ten point five
thousand followers on Instagram way to
go congrats you guys that is Jenny video
but what people do is just take pictures
of it and then put it in a collage and
don't even give them credit and then
pass it all around hey free marketing
yeah
all right Brian next story there is this
British Airways stewardess that went on
this little snapchat rant right before
she went on her flight to Nigeria so she
was leaving from London to Nigeria and
one of her friends filmed the snapchat
rants and uploaded it in a went viral
and now this woman has been fired thanks
friend
what a awesome friend huh right so I'm
gonna show you why was it really funny
or cool you you guys came okay when he
filmed it while she was snapchatting but
she got fired from the the third person
video not the snapchat video well they
were recording the snapchat video Oh
save it
yeah I betcha sounds classy no matter
what she's talking about
[Music]
all the night they've all gonna be there
I got enough leg room cause all their
bbc's are in their way how's that info
looks like that's so true but she
actually says yeah it was her first she
said that she's gonna go to Nigeria and
get some BBC like it's a dope thing and
then later she started using it as an
insult like I didn't I don't get it
though this is what she said all right
so all of yous are getting ready for
your Friday night getting in the
pre-drinks you know as you do and I'm
here getting ready to go to work put on
a yellow lifejacket point out the exits
hand out chicken or beef
what sort of Friday night is this for me
the upside is I'm going to Nigeria and
there's gonna be bear ggc's I'm joking
I'm joking we expect no she's like those
from the airline she continues saying
all the Nigerians are gonna be there
like gave me Coca Cola give me beef why
you have no beef left
I want beef and I'm just gonna be there
like sorry sir we ran out of beef all
the Nigerians are gonna be there asking
for [ __ ] upgrades because they
haven't got enough leg room because the
BBC's are in the way big dicks like this
swinging from side to side that's what
she said
not racist she's just being a complainer
yeah like she didn't say anything
negative so to speak about Nigerians is
more so about her job yeah yeah
and she mixed in a little bit of comedy
it was comedy some stereotypes
stereotype but not racist yeah so this
is dude but that's one of those awesome
stereotypes to have she's cute so yeah
she's now branded as a racism yes she
got fired I would brand her as a BBC
lover
she talks about it so much and it's I'm
I'm pretty [ __ ] sure she's landing in
Nigeria and she's doing one of these
things shaking the water bottle yeah
she's looking forward to landing there
dropped my BBC yeah
she was super comfortable saying all
that stuff so to me when somebody's that
comfortable if they're races they're
gonna say some way out [ __ ] like they're
gonna say some mean things to make their
friends laugh especially because that's
snapchats private it's not like she's a
public figure and I was following her
her friends call her she could have said
whatever so yeah I don't see that as
being racist why did her friend upload
this one because they just thought it
was funny
well the thing is this woman so Joanne
she's saying that she's been framed by
another British Airlines employee
because they were encouraging her and
egging her on to say things like that so
that's what she's claimed airline to
airline peace know her co-worker Oh
coworker co-worker sabotage it's like oh
my god that was so funny say it again
and then boom girl upload this [ __ ] yeah
well she was recording it herself but I
guess they were egging her on to put it
on her snapchat
according to her so I'm not sure yeah
but that's not an excuse girl I don't
see what was so bad and that's coming
right from a black person who is very
sensitive to racist [ __ ]
she didn't say she stereotyped for sure
but it wasn't in dad [ __ ] bet I think
it's just unprofessional while you're
wearing the uniform definitely and then
you're representing the company and then
anybody that like goes out on social
media and talks about their company in a
negative way even if it's a joke I think
you know it could it's kind of you could
get fired for that that's very used to
so after they fired a bunch of people
with stuff like that and then rules have
changed
mmm like your social media is yours it's
private you know I'm saying now the fact
that she's on the plane and then the you
should
oh she was heading to she was on the
plane she was so it's like if I were
heading to good - she's in the car right
she's in the car yeah
oh she's oh yeah she's on her way to
work she's wearing a uniform that's the
part that got admire she has it blocked
true I guess maybe they recognized the
pattern of her scarf but also I think
that intent matters - like it's on
snapchat only your friends can see it
right like it's not it's not like she
did this on Facebook she's and she
didn't do it on a public forum I mean is
is it considered public I feel like it's
not I mean it can be but my thing is
everybody uses snapchat as if it's
private
with her knowing or feeling like his
Providence just her friends she could
have said a lot worse if those were her
intentions so that's true because the
way I see snapchat is like group chat
yeah like you're not you don't think
that other people see your [ __ ] unless
you're a public figure
alright for our last story this one's a
crazy one and I want to warn you guys
that it is pretty graphic this Chinese
woman she could there's a video of her
giving birth in the middle of the street
and this just went viral this art
actually she a kung fu master no no it's
like earlier when you said something
about like diarrhea birth or something
yeah like you're pretty close she just
farted a baby out ya know so you can see
her pulling her pants down as soon as
you clean her pants down the baby just
plops out and just lands on the yeah but
also keep in mind that is pretty natural
like almost every other animal does it
that way yeah sure I don't know if
that's that natural you really want to
be squatting at least she's price
playing horse dance though she was going
after the kid popped out she was still
standing and then you could see the baby
plummet so here's an umbilical cords
like a bungee cord sir I've seen a horse
gift give a person a horse baby just
goes like they're built for that [ __ ] so
here we go that's just mom talk okay
overprotective over worried
the baby is blurt out [ __ ] all right
here we go
oh my god nathan is there a friend
helping her get the husband the friends
filming her there's gotta be all yes oh
[ __ ] just like that pick it up
who's crying what is she doing why don't
you just staring at it what she's I
think she's in shock that's [ __ ] dumb
mom what the hell I know why should just
staring at it like I thought I was that
she's like leaning away from the baby
she was like I don't want nothing to do
a baby boy pose drop the baby up maybe
she was scared to look like I think
she's in shock I think that would happen
to me I'm just like what the [ __ ] do I
do in my okay should I be in a dog
should there be a doctor like I don't
know Janna and as she's squatting you
see like the blood trickling down the
street thank God I know when I first saw
this my mouth just dropped my jaw just
dropped and then I was just like what
are you doing big library baby I thought
like the maternal instinct would kick in
and my god yeah like you know I feel
like any other animal that gives birth
like if he's a predator comes to mom
when I get defense she might not be all
there mentally to cuz if yeah she's
standing there in pain and then as soon
as she drops the pack she's already at
the point of like by the time she
dropped her pants the kid was already at
least halfway out cuz the baby yeah you
could hear the thud - oh yeah yeah that
it's that it's to closer and I don't
want it Oh God
did it land on its back I don't know
because they blurred it
that baby was really white in color yeah
and it's covered in a little sacking
protective sex like that frickin mucus
membrane yeah egg whites Oh little
eggshell
oh yeah that's crazy I mean [ __ ] easy
birth for her well yeah what swimming I
like pushing forever maybe she has a ton
of kids do you think she's been in pain
just walking around all day and then
like that was the last point maybe not
maybe she never felt anything maybe it
was just like oh [ __ ] this feels weird I
got to take a [ __ ] and then I just came
out I've heard of stories like I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure she was in
pain but you're not Asians like they're
like [ __ ] I'm gonna deal with it and
then she's just putting tiger balm on
her temple the whole time go away maybe
I've heard stories from women that like
she thought she had to take a [ __ ] and
then she's not sitting on the toilet and
then she's like going into like active
labor in the kids commands like oh [ __ ]
so I saw was she Labor's the baby in the
toilet
she was about to but she was at the
hospital doing this she's about it and
the nurse was like oh my god I see a
head so they had to like move the bed
into the bathroom and then have her dude
there I was thinking that but then my
thing is like let's say this lady felt
like oh [ __ ] I have to [ __ ] there well
maybe she started feeling like the head
coming out and she's like all [ __ ] this
is the different hole like oh yeah maybe
I'm starting to lean toward Joe with
them
yeah because I even either one of those
scenarios she if she felt like she had
to poop she probably would have tried to
go to the bathroom if she felt like it
with the baby she probably was set to
[ __ ] down or laid down instead of yeah
maybe she's not mentally there
I hope this baby's okay yeah she just
not taking off her clothes that goes
nothing mmm [ __ ] what if she never even
realize you is actually pregnant
well there's he's a man at Fargo Wow
pregnant belly
you never know the baby's like play-doh
hope you guys enjoyed that episode of JK
news make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here
[Music]